Very delighted to have the writer and director of the film screenagers uh,
Dr. Delaney Ruston.
So let's welcome her
Delaney.
Tell us about just the,
what the film was about and uh,
where you got this idea from.
Sure.
We'll screenagers,
uh,
is a film that looks at my personal story and stories of all different age
groups about the impact of all this screen time on kids.
And you know,
really as a physician,
I was interested in this,
but most importantly as a mom with two young teenagers who wanted more and more
screen time,
I was really figuring out like,
oh,
what do I do?
Feeling really out of control and often is the case when I feel this way is I
started filming and now here we are with screenagers out for almost a year now.
And it is just creating a huge movement and I'm really excited about that and
excited to be here at Google talking.
Yeah.
What has been the response from parents and even from some kids are teenagers as
you've shown this to?
Yeah,
I mean parents really want solutions and so I really made sure that the film was
about that.
And what I really wanted to do is get people talking because it was interesting.
I had been doing films on mental health issues and I did one for example on
global mental health.
Trying to find people in China and India to talk about mental illness is not
easy.
I came back here trying to find parents to talk about struggles in their home
was so much harder and I realized how private parenting is and so I wanted the
film to be shown in communities and get kids,
parents,
teachers,
all of us talking about how are we going to manage this for our kids,
how are we going to get them to manage it?
And the response has been,
that's great.
I brought my kid,
we had a great talk.
We're still talking.
Um,
educators are talking now with their kids about these issues more.
So that's been great.
Kids really like the science,
which has been fun.
Sometimes they're defensive and then it's a great conversation to have with
them.
You know,
what did this bring up with you?
what our appropriate screen time limits.
So it's been across the board,
critical in making discussions happen and that's really what my goal was.
Well it's a phenomenal film.
And seeing it and seeing it,
it's very funny.
We were laughing at the,
I came in a group is laughing a few times during the,
the,
the screening.
I was laughing.
Uh,
what was so interesting was,
Whoa,
I guess what were some of the surprises that you've found is that I've gone to
last present myself just from listening to be like,
Oh wow,
okay.
That's,
that hits the nail on the head.
But what were some of the surprises that you found that you may not have known
before?
Just outside of your own child that your own experience with your own child that
other parents were expecting?
Okay.
Well.
Um,
you know,
first I have to say when my daughter saw the film for the first time,
um,
he's in the film here I was,
I had been making it for you know,
a couple of years.
And the first reaction was I don't realize other kids were dealing with all
these issues around rules or not.
I'm like,
Tessa,
what did we get?
Oh yes.
The only one who he was.
And you know,
I think parents often feel that way too and we don't,
it's particularly interesting that parents feel self conscious about talking
about solutions.
You know,
you do hear parents saying I'm struggling,
but in terms of kind of saying what kind of rules they've tried and haven't
tried,
you feel really judged.
And that's kind of the con,
that's what I really wanted to say.
We got to get out there.
We've got to be talking about how do we decide when tech should be put away and
in what spaces.
And that's not necessarily easy to do when it is so dopamine rich.
And to answer your question in terms of we know surprises that I found looking
at the science was first and foremost that there,
there's no other age in our life then our teenage years when our pleasure center
is physically the biggest that you have the most dopamine there at any time.
So it wasn't that it was our first time kiss that it was so great.
It was actually that we were like pumping dopamine at that time.
And so what the kids' experiences are and their vulnerability to that intense
dopamine rushes from some of the most fascinating video games and all sorts of
things.
You know,
that's what we really have to be aware of and be responsible about,
you know,
stepping up to the challenge that we can create balance around this.
Well,
what,
what is it,
how'd you do it with your daughter when you look at,
I mean,
you can't with this contract and that was really funny or you made baseless four
or five page contracts for her.
And so,
but what does that balance when you have,
because it was interesting what you asked your daughter was,
um,
you know,
why do you want a phone?
Convince me why you need this smartphone,
why you need this iPhone or whatever.
And she has all my friends have it and everyone has it.
So I mean,
as a parent,
how do you say no to a kid when everyone else is doing it?
You know,
because at that age is just,
it doesn't matter what their parents say just matters.
Everyone else is doing it.
So I should be like,
yeah,
I,
you know,
it's interesting,
one of the movements that we've started with a film is called Tech Talk Tuesday.
And it's exactly about having these kinds of conversations that are easy to not
have to do because you're just busy and you just have a reactive answer,
you know?
Well,
I don't care if everyone is doing right.
So tech talk Tuesday,
every week we give discussion prompts to as part of the solution,
how to have these conversations.
And actually today's tech talk Tuesday,
um,
on the screenagers movie website is exactly that age.
Well,
that question of what age is appropriate to get a kid at a mobile device,
a smartphone.
And,
um,
there's a,
there's a lot of discussion about it.
What I've seen over making this film is of course kids at and younger ages are
getting smartphones.
One recent survey,
7% of four year olds on their own smart phone,
75% of four year olds own their own mobile device.
A lot of those or some sort of like a iPad.
So,
you know,
if we don't stop and have these discussions about what do we do,
there's a,
there's a big trend that we all see happening and I don't know if we're always
going to get this right.
You know,
when your kid asked this and ask that and you're kind of coming up with what you
feel.
I think there's two things.
I think we have a lot more data now in the past 10 years,
so we need to be data driven,
you know,
definitely this is emotional.
So it's,
you know,
emotionally fueled.
It's our kids,
but it should be data driven and I think that when we do that we're going to
parent with integrity and that's what we'll look back and feel good about rather
than it's too late.
Nothing I can do.
It's actually not too late.
If you have a teenager and there have devices in their bedroom and you look at
the study that shows much more convincingly how poor sleep affects emotional
development,
academic development,
you might say,
Hey,
I know you've been pretty good.
You've had your phone there.
I know you put it on the other side of the room or it's silent,
but I'm just going to feel better because self control goes down when we're
tired.
All these things,
let's talk about the science,
but I think we need to all have our devices out of the bedroom.
That's an example of having these kinds of conversations,
doing them commonly,
weekly Tech Talk Tuesday and kids actually really respect that.
You're modeling to them that you're going to do this with integrity and there
might be frustrated in the beginning,
but actually they'll feel the difference and they'll be happy that you did that.
Is your son getting off a little bit easier than your daughter?
Cause she's kind of taking the brunt of it,
right?
Cause she,
yeah,
13 I guess when you did this whole contract,
it's interesting that you say that.
So my,
my son's a senior now in high school and I really was kind of thinking this
issue of,
oh he's an older teenager,
you know,
what can I do now?
It's his,
and I notice he just was,
when we were in the kitchen,
kind of as he was moving around,
just a lot more on his phone.
And I said,
and it was just snuck up on us and I said,
you know what's going on?
It seems like you're really kind of always on.
And he said,
he's said,
wow,
you know,
you're right.
And he went off his phone for a week just to kind of see how that felt.
There was some frustrating times where he couldn't get directions or you know,
some things and we had to talk about,
okay,
how are you going to preempt that?
And he said it's helped him to reset.
So it was a good reminder to me that all of us kind of need the,
sometimes just a little poke and a little thing.
And it's ultimately the goal though is really to get our kids to have that
mindfulness that they can experiment with this because it truly is just a daily
experiment about how do we live to our fullest when we have lots of things that
we want to do online and offline.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so gonna open up the ions questions.
Uh,
so one thing I've heard about anecdotally is a teenager's having a lot more
ergonomic problems like in the wrist and neck.
And they used to,
I was curious if you ran across any of that in your investigations.
Yeah,
I mean that absolutely posture and other,
um,
uh,
some tendinitis things are,
you know,
happening more.
It's,
it's not,
um,
also near sightedness is a discussion.
We don't have the definitive,
but absolutely anybody can be prone and get,
it's not,
you know,
how much increased risk that is per person.
It's hard to say because there's so many genetic and other factors going in.
But with the different game devices in particular,
you have some kids who were playing games six hours a day and some of them are
prone to having pain in those regions.
Obviously the movie focused on teenagers,
but I'm wondering,
you know,
younger kids are just as much into technology and they don't have the ability to
be rational,
you know,
to sort of understand datadriven um,
uh,
explanation.
So what advice do you have on younger kids?
I have a four year old nephew who,
you know,
had a temper tantrum when the iPad was taken away.
So what can you,
you know,
we as parents do to deal with the younger kids and technology [inaudible]
um,
you know,
I think there's a lot of discussion about how we set parameters and have kids'
involvement.
And I think even at a young age,
that is reasonable and a great approach.
And so even in that setting,
you know,
would it be more helpful if I gave you 10 minutes or five minute warning before
your screen time is over?
And that will go a long way.
And that made them feel like they're involved.
But absolutely they might cry and say,
no rule ever work here.
And it's a question of,
you know,
doing that kind of work now versus paying a lot more later.
And I'll give you an example or the same study I mentioned earlier with young
kids.
It turns out that 25% of those parents are using devices for kids to go to bed
width and over half of them are using devices when they are shopping or want to
get things done right.
Particularly also obviously when a kid is upset.
So one concern is that are we training them when they're uncomfortable,
when they're upset to go to a screen as opposed to self soothe,
talk to a friend,
exercise,
other things,
you know,
we're really giving that dopamine quick screen right away.
And what I mean by pay later is that as it gets stronger and bigger and if
they're really prone to this affinity,
it can be a lot bigger later on.
So we do have a lot on screenagers movie.com about addressing the different
ages.
And I'd say,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm so fascinated as a physician and all of us as individuals here,
we know that certain people have strong reactions to um,
pleasurable stimuli.
It's just a known thing.
I do not like wine wine at all,
but I know a lot of you must really like wine,
right?
I love sugar to the,
like,
I can't even put words my husband sugar could totally live without it.
Right.
And I,
and it's really,
there's a same thing going on for a lot of people with,
with screens,
with video games,
whatever the different things are prone to.
And as a parent,
I would just say to have a real wake up call in terms of if there's a pattern
where they're having really extreme withdrawal feelings and fighting and
aggression around screen time being turned off,
it's a good time to say,
okay,
you know,
I need to get really mindful about this and how are we going to manage this?
I need to read about this,
I need to talk to others and it's going to go a long way.
We see that in the film with a single mother who has a child and she was a
single,
yeah,
grandmother,
right?
Yeah.
Who had the kid who she just like,
he just loves his video games,
particularly where he punched the wall,
kicks the law and stuff like that and just like,
no,
and Helen,
it's interesting kind of thing.
One of my favorite parts in the movie is when she goes to see that super cool
social worker counselor.
Because again,
as a physician that,
you know,
I work with a ton of counselors because you know,
the way that we may frame and the outside help is so critical that I really
wanted to put that in there.
And I don't think,
you know,
I think we really need a movement.
Uh,
Lisa and I,
my,
um,
coproducer is here with me today.
I'm so happy about that.
Um,
we're,
we're talking about today,
we really need a crisis line.
Um,
you know,
restart where you saw that deals with kids who really do have addiction issues
around screen time.
They get flooded with calls,
but it doesn't even have to be that high a level.
But I,
I have people now call me a lot and I do kind of,
you know,
impromptu ongoing counseling for them,
brainstorming and helping them to get new ways of thinking and approaching this
because it's intensive,
you know,
30% of families in America report that they are struggling daily about screen
time with their kids.
It's happened.
It's also you don't an opportunity.
Yeah.
It's like if we can use us that opportunity of how we're going to have
resolution of conflicts,
that's going to go a long way to teach them in their work,
in the relationships.
It's the number one thing that predicts for relationships is not how many cool
things you guys do together or mountain biking and Moran,
but how you resolve conflicts.
And so learning how to do that with small frequent conversations with really I
take really pinning yourself down what are a few times that we don't think that
tech should be used so that our relationships can be stronger.
Why is it that 70% of parents allow kids to use devices in the car when that can
be really valuable time.
Like let's wake up and say sorry,
it's not safe.
It's not great.
Let's,
let's listen to music together.
Let's be together.
There are these kinds of discussions we're having about rethinking how are we
going to create these cherished moments.
Interesting too.
Cause like it's,
I'm trying to,
it's seeing the kids be so attached to their screens and,
and go right to the video game and try to be immersed in these worlds using,
cause when I was a kid,
when we were kids we would go play and the forest and we would have to pretend
like we were the Ninja turtles or we were the power rangers or whatever,
you know,
and like how do you,
how would you suggest a parent going after that or going about that with their
child saying,
you know,
there is a world out there and just in your head and you can actually pretend in
play out there versus just having to immerse yourself into world
or craft or Minecraft or this,
you know,
I think that it gets you a bigger question of why do we care that kids not just
beyond screens all the time.
And you know,
as a parent,
as we're,
I think that's really important that we think about where our kids are at more
as a mentor teacher and where we want to make sure that they get to,
to offline experiences.
And I break it down into three main things.
Creativity,
communication and competency.
And what's really interesting about what you're saying about creativity,
like create with your mind and be out there in the world is it turns out when
they survey what kids are doing on screens,
only 3% of the time is content creation.
It's pretty amazing.
You know,
when they're,
you,
you can make videos,
you can make music,
you can write blogs.
And frankly,
um,
you know,
the reason is to create and to,
to work,
uh,
is much harder than to play and to watch.
And so our brain often will default.
Even though doing that work,
you actually feel better afterwards and longer and you gain,
you know,
self confidence from what we do.
So I think that if your kid is not spending a fair amount of time doing mental
creation or other creation as one of those things,
creation,
communication,
and,
and a competency,
I think that's a great starting point to say,
Hey,
I want to make sure you're also creating offline.
You know,
and having time to think with your brain and write it down.
And also let's relook at what you're doing online.
You're in this game,
that fabulous.
Hey,
there's this program by which you could develop a game.
So I think having that,
that mindset can really be effective.
So thank you very much.
That was really amazing.
I guess probably a wake up call
for many people.
Um,
so I have two questions.
First question.
Um,
it seems that you also touched on the,
uh,
digital identity part and how we believe in how we help kids.
Uh,
personally I found really brave that you put your family,
your own family in that movie and I would like to discuss that.
How did you,
what was the process of deciding how many of those scenes and how much of your
family you should expose to the world?
And I assume this movie goes really,
really well,
which I really hope and a wish,
eh,
your kids will probably become celebrities through this movie.
So how,
how do you weigh these thing of doing something for the world that is really
meaningful?
Vestors uh,
introducing risks to your own family.
You will,
man.
Well,
you know,
I have to say,
I wasn't at all intending to put my family into this film.
I thought it was,
you know,
just looking at video games and social media and I didn't think it called for
that,
but it actually was because it was hard for me to find families who would let me
in in real time.
Again,
I think that we create,
we totally crazy eve,
um,
true real moments,
you know,
we,
and even reality TV is so we now we see it as so doctored.
So,
um,
that's ultimately my kids had been used to my filming in the home for so long
and we didn't know what the film would be calm.
They didn't know.
Fortunately since mainly it's my daughter,
she has been okay and happy with the film and she does a lot of the Q and A's
with me.
Um,
she has moments when she sees the parts in there and she's like,
oh.
And recently this last week I tried to film her on some emotional stuff that's
happening and she's 15 and she said,
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to be filmed their mom.
I'm,
I'm happy now.
It's great about screenagers.
I'm just not sure.
So it'll be interesting to,
to see.
Um,
I think though getting,
you know,
it'd be,
it would be great if everyone did this.
Have your kids film you about what do you think you were struggling with,
with balance and screen time and film them?
I mean,
there's a,
there's an incredible,
um,
we use it a lot of medicine to see how we communicate as physicians,
right?
We filmed the medical students and then we evaluate that and everyone can be
creating and have that self reflection again,
anything that we can do to make our kids more mindful,
more curious about all of this as opposed to just immediately pulled in.
We're doing half our battle.
It really are.
How can we make the most out of this treasure?
And whether it means,
first of all,
I would hope is that it will not become a,
like a compulsory screening.
But at least through this movement we go far away and like 60,
70,
90% of students,
teenagers,
students,
the u s will,
uh,
be able to watch it with our parents.
Uh,
hopefully,
perhaps the regulators also,
we'll have a chance,
I don't know if we can have a screening at the congress or something,
but,
uh,
so if you could,
if you could talk a little bit more how we could take this movement and move it
along.
And also one more for rob,
if you could have a follow up to that movement to see how actually having seen
the movement has affected the families and uh,
the,
uh,
you know,
I witness,
so to answer your first question about how to build this movement,
how do we get all families and kids to see this movie because it's a one hour of
their life and yet screentime is somewhere around seven hours a day for kids and
adults,
not including school work.
And not including work,
you know,
it's an incredible,
so with this one hour to get us to think,
what do we agree with?
What do we don't,
what does the science,
what science do we need?
We are all for it.
We have,
I'm now almost 2000 screenings that are scheduled,
you know,
that had been booked around the country and in about 20 different countries.
Um,
and we're working with many different companies who have brought it,
you know,
um,
Pixar and Lucas films and a lot of tech companies and all over.
And we really,
but we really believe that it is about bringing people together.
And so@screenagersmovie.com anyone can bring it to their church,
to their afterschool activity program.
So please,
you know,
I think that all of you help us and getting the word out to bring it to schools
and whatnot.
And the other thing that everyone can do today is that tech talk.
Tuesday,
we're next week will be our 50th week of doing it.
If you take a pledge to do one of them on our website,
it's,
it's basically saying to your kids,
Hey,
I want to take a pledge to not be reactive.
I,
he,
what I always do is I do the grab and stab.
I like grab my daughter's phone and then I kind of like staring her in the eyes,
like I told you not to be on it.
Then.
And through doing these tech talk,
Tuesdays,
calm conversations,
I really become less reactive and more curious and an able to deal with that.
So I hope people will do the tech talk Tuesday pledge.
Um,
in terms of a followup movie,
you know,
something just a couple of weeks ago,
um,
the today show had a group of teenagers that they showed the film to and then
they had them give up their phone and technology for a week and they saw what
happened.
So it's at our website and it's fun to watch,
but that,
so we'll,
we'll see what the next film full feature film will be.
Yeah.
Um,
so this is a really funny like timing in terms of the screening because actually
I'm a very recent like teenager myself and I also,
uh,
for the past month I've given up like social media just to basically disconnect,
what was mentioned in a movie.
Like we are hooked and addicted,
but a lot of us have that yearning to not be an and to not be like I'm
controlled by what we feel like is,
I'm very addicting.
Uh,
so I just want to say first of all,
this is such a great film and uh,
really touched upon a lot of very relatable experiences.
I'm already like being on social media,
I'm so much more productive at work.
I'm actually doing things that I enjoy outside of just like mindlessly
scrolling.
Um,
I think when like,
I don't know if you've thought about this or have the answer,
but something I'm just thinking about is the term,
the condition of the screen.
So like obviously if we have screens it's very distracting and something we can
look at.
And you know,
wherever you go,
the cafe,
the bus,
like everywhere,
everyone is just looking down on the screens.
But more and more people now are saying that the future of tech is a very
quickly becoming screamed less.
Um,
and the Google home,
you know,
Alexa,
like all those things,
um,
the watch and,
or I guess the wash is a screen,
but you go to,
I mean,
right.
Um,
so do you think that the problem lies in the screen itself or is there something
just about technology?
Um,
that is the real challenge?
Well,
you know,
I think you've really hit on something that is key is what you did is you
replaced it right?
And as a physician that it works in primary care,
half of what I do is behavior change.
And it's not okay,
you gotta Stop Smoking cigarettes.
It's what are we going to do in place of that urge when you have it right.
It never works to replace with a vacuum.
So fantastic that you are doing other things that you're excited about.
Um,
I would say that the other thing that I'm excited that you're talking about is
that you're modeling,
right?
You are here in the cafe and you're probably having a better conversation or
you're just being breathing.
I know you do a lot of mindfulness stuff.
You're taking that moment to kind of refresh your brain and that modeling is a
key.
It turns out that,
uh,
I just learned that 80% of parents think they actually are good models.
If you are highly educated,
you were more likely to think that.
And I think it's in part because we justify I have to do it for work,
you know,
and kids,
well,
it's different.
We need to figure out how to model in terms of change.
Like one behavior.
Like,
you know what?
I'm going to work,
I'm going to say to my kids,
I really am checking too much during dinner and I'm going to say to them,
I'm going to work on this guys.
Help me.
You know,
because to change behavior,
it takes a lot of different issues.
Again on the screenagers movie site.
I spent a lot of time on that because you made it seem easy,
but it's often not so easy.
Your real question though is in terms of screen time,
is it the screen?
What is it?
I think a big thing that we have to know is that our brain does not like to be
bored.
Right.
And I don't know if you just saw the study that came out in science magazine
when they put people into a room with nothing to do for 15 minutes,
over a quarter of them had the um,
chose to give themselves an electric shock rather than just sit there.
Even though prior they had paid experimental money to not be shocked.
They didn't like the shock.
It was just being bored and sitting there was nerve wracking.
And when we give kids now these devices in the car,
the car has so much cool things driving by.
If that's not kind of like cool to be like thinking and daydreaming,
have the music,
whatever.
We're really setting them up to be more and comfortable having those moments
where there's boredom and then our brain,
ideally we'll find new ideas to go to.
Right.
Cause I'm bored and brilliant as a whole concept that look,
a lot of creativity comes from those moments,
but in the moment and the immediacy,
we get scared of those moments.
Well,
thank you so much for being here,
doctor of the lane.